boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host alan sakyan we
are still on site in brooklyn in new
york we are now going to be talking
about all things comedy all things
writing all things how we can learn from
rejections we have emily winter joining
us hi thanks for coming on the show
thanks for having me i'm really excited
for this conversation i actually found
emily's work she was on the today show
last week this is in january this is
recordings happening in january and i
noticed how you were speaking about how
important it was as a comedian as a
writer as just anyone going through
wanting to pursue their dreams going
through a period of getting rejected
it's putting yourself out there and and
getting accepted getting rejected and
all this kind of stuff anyway i found
you and i was like i'm in new york i
want to talk to emily so we've made this
happen i'm really excited um emily's so
here's a bit on emily's background
besides you know just being on the today
show um her work has also appeared in
the new yorker in the new york times on
npr um which she also writes for npr's
ask ask me another and also she's been
writing for about 15 years doing comedy
for about seven years and she also hosts
her own podcast called how to produce
live comedy which is really important
because it helps people with
understanding how to throw live events
which is so crucial this is how we gain
build community and we learn um
and she's a former editorial director of
sparknotes and yeah and a bunch of other
stuff and she's a also at nbc late night
writers workshop script judge so a bunch
of cool uh background with emily sh and
i wanna i wanna jump right into knowing
about how you even came to you know came
to realize uh writing but before that
sorry before that um
i really like having a big history
perspective on things so i want to ask
you about this like humans find
themselves now as
stewards of earth
and
humanity's gotten really complicated
over the last hundred years with a
massive population increase massive
exponential technologies now in the last
couple decades so where do you see the
current state of humanity oh boy well i
i think it's a mess i think you're right
um
yeah it's a big mess i uh
don't feel i mean
i get really sad when i think about it
and i'm like oh should i be like telling
more jokes that will like turn people
vegetarian like what is my like what
should what's my role in this and it's
really hard like when you think about
where we are and
all of the sad things like to just
function in the world so
that's probably why i got into comedy
because like it's just too sad
sorry was i supposed to be more upbeat
no no you're good you're being realistic
because it is it's a little it's a lot
messy
yeah i'm engaged right now and i'm
planning a wedding and like a very
important part of congrats oh thank you
um
a very important part of like you sure
70 years
i hope so um but like i don't want to
have kids for this very reason and i
just i feel like bringing another person
into an overpopulated world is like
i
you know i'm lucky that i don't have the
strong mommy feelings and i think i
understand people fighting that but like
i i definitely feel like
it's not really the responsible thing to
do
now maybe i'll get the feelings that my
friends have that like oh i have to have
a kid and i'll just say i don't care if
it's not responsible i'm doing it anyway
because i just have to but right now i
just i don't want to do that you know it
just feels wrong damn that's a really
profound message because i feel very
similarly
that we have so many pressing issues
that society's got to kind of like grow
up from kindergarten in many ways
ethically morally we have to figure out
the resource flows amongst one another
to raise the baseline of living for
everyone more effectively
there's just not really space and time
for uh for people to be dedicating
energy and resources towards
procreating
with there's so many babies that need
homes
yeah and this is like there's different
colors on the color wheel so there's
certain people having six kids still in
developing arts for those certain people
that have no kids right so there's
different colors but i'm glad that that
you're aware enough to be like yo i need
to lay off i need to see what i can do
about mimetics or disseminating ideas to
more people through comedy and through
writing i mean i definitely don't feel
like a good person like i'm not like oh
my god i'm like out here doing the work
trying to make the world a better place
like my sister's an anthropologist and
she really is trying to make the world a
better place so i'm like ah my parents
did okay one of the kids is doing the
work and the other one's just kind of
[ __ ] around but wait can i swear on
this totally yeah
so but i yeah i mean i try where i can
but i don't compost i'm not vegan so i
really cannot i really can't those are
the two measurements
i don't do anything yeah yeah yeah
yeah um and then the
uh well at least if we are potentially
you know conscious of
even even doing something like smiling
when you walk down the street or not
um punching down when you're talking to
people on the internet right there's
these things also cascade big waves just
like um
eating not eating
tons of meat or composting um things
like that
okay
we'll get more big history along the way
emily how does one even find themselves
you know a decade and a half ago really
enjoying writing and wanting to get
deeper into it how did you find yourself
there um i think i always liked writing
i was just um i kind of had a natural
knack for it and i don't have a natural
knack for many things so that was like
oh i'm going to pursue this but
i grew up in the midwest and i didn't
really know
anything about like entertainment
industry or comedy
and i i don't know i just i majored in
journalism and my first
job out of college was writing for a
newspaper in wisconsin and i just like
didn't really i couldn't really figure
out beyond that how to be a writer um
beyond just like being a newspaper
reporter or an author um and that seemed
scary so
yeah so i i mean
i think i had to learn after college and
like as college was ending like
it's actually being funny doing funny
writing that is your passion
um which was scary because i had
prepared for a job in
news yeah
yeah and it's good that you also
realize that there's like writing has
evolved a lot more from
books to
to newspapers to now the digital
publications are there's so many and
there's so many options of diverse
writing you can write about specific
sciences or you can write about like you
were pointing towards like news or
comedy and so that's kind of where you
found yourself from finding a footing is
more in like online
writing um i would say so i mean it's
hard i've had so many different writing
jobs like when i moved to new york my
first job was a vogue editor's assistant
so it was like devil where's prada and
we were writing a script together i mean
her writing assisted on a script and
then i um
gosh then i was a production assistant
then i worked as a book packager um
so coming up with book ideas and then
fleshing them out and stuff so and
pitching them to publishers um and then
i worked for spark notes and ran their
blog and just stayed for a really long
time and so i like sort of worked my way
up so i've done kind of everything and
then i worked in tv
in a couple different places uh now
radio so it
everywhere you know i think
it's all the same a joke is a you know a
joke is a joke whether you read it on
paper or hear it on the radio for those
that don't know the nuance differences
between what it's like on
writing for publication or writing on
radio or being on a like a television
program tell us a little bit about those
differences sure um so
i mean writing for television there's a
couple different things you you know
you're either like submitting scripts um
like in a in a script form uh to try to
get jobs on like scripted shows but um
here in new york more of the jobs are
like late night
so that's just more like packets where
you're writing topical jokes
on a really quick turnaround to get
considered for those jobs um
the radio job that i currently work in
is very similar to that because we're
writing for uh we're writing for things
that are happening that week in that
month
so they are more like topical jokes um
yeah i guess
obviously we all know what a blog looks
like and blog posting looks like
um in the literary world putting a book
proposal together is
a sort of a big deal you know there's a
lot of research involved you're really
trying to sell
both like the writer and the concept uh
to publishers um so that's when i worked
in book packaging that was a whole
different type of
writing i guess and then sometimes ghost
writing a book which is
fun and scary and hard and big and yeah
yeah
and then so now the comedy sort of
entering it likely always has been part
of all different aspects of our lives
but now really we're starting to see it
pretty much everywhere we go there's a
version of comedy even in science and
science comedy science communication
it's kind of it's kind of exciting to
see it there
because science is also a very funny
thing in so many ways now
tell us a bit about you know we see now
comedy being something that
is like a muscle that you gotta train
you gotta get really good at being able
to like be quick on your feet and and
and when you do that you can almost like
lean liven up crowds you can liven up uh
your conversation between people but
then there's like
people that can sometimes be potentially
you know they're like oh well i'm trying
to have a serious conversation so how do
you like figure out where to
like how do you use humor yeah tell us
about that one thing that i thought that
you just said that was so interesting
was like the like talking about making
that connection and when you're on stage
so i've been doing stand-up for about
seven years and
i never thought that i would love it but
i i loved it immediately
and when you're on stage and your jokes
are working
and everyone is having the same good
time there's like an electricity in the
air that is just like it's like
it's so weird you can feel it and it's
like such a cool
feeling and it i just it's like it's so
real even though it's invisible and it's
amazing so
that is like something that i am always
chasing that wonderful feeling and it's
like community it's something that it's
larger than the sum of its parts you
know it's just it's beautiful um
what were you talking about oh when to
be serious um i think it's really
actually a good question i feel strongly
about this i can't stand i think a lot
of people can't stand comedians that are
always on like they're always trying to
like be the center of attention and it's
like dude you're at a birthday party for
your friend we're all just like sitting
at a dinner like it's not about you like
stop trying to like win an award for
funniest person at the table you know so
it's just like i don't know i think like
you have to turn your joke brain off
sometimes to like spare other people and
also to spare yourself because it is
work like looking at the world and like
taking an object and
twisting it in every which way to find
every angle on it is like a lot of
mental energy and so i think like we
as comedians you're kind of in a way
always trying you know you should be i
guess like looking at the world from
different angles but like you gotta give
it a rest and you gotta give everybody
else a rest too you know it's not nice i
don't know those are really good points
first you mentioned this sort of this
this feeling of electricity that comes
up in a room that's all laughing that
sort of
energy i think is probably one of the
coolest things to feel period is is when
you know you're really connecting with
an audience and either they're you know
their jaws are dropped because they're
super in awe about what you're saying or
they're laughing their asses off and
you're just having a good time from that
that that feeling of connection with a
large group of people it takes really
hard work to learn how to do that really
well
and so we'll we'll talk more um
about that
later as well and then you also
mentioned how
this is funny because i i also think
it's really important to look at objects
from different angles and the situations
and poke fun at them but i do think it
can be crazy sometimes dealing with
people that are oh my god
give it a rest yeah totally
coming in to be funny all the time
just like aren't you you must not be
doing well enough in your career if you
need like if you need constant attention
outside of it just like
do you think seth meyers
goes out to dinner and try and tries to
like wow the whole restaurant no he does
he leaves his work at his work i'm sure
he's very pleasant to hang out with but
just like people at the top of their
game don't need to be constantly
impressing people with their you know
by being loud and silly and yeah yeah
just be a person
and this is good it's like you can be
yeah you can be chill and you can be
serious and you can be humorous and you
can mix them all in it's kind of
it's funny there's different strokes for
different folks what's
what okay this seems to be something
that's now arising more and more in our
culture there's this
[ __ ] and it's not just in common it's
just political correctness in general um
it's uh it's people feeling offended um
you know
and at times you know rightfully so um
also on the other side of things it's
kind of like a
dictating or
speech policing a little bit like where
how do you see that
um yeah i i i think
it
it's a little complicated but i am i
tend to air with the people who say be
politically correct like if you
if what you're saying is offensive if
it's offending multiple people we were
talking about this a little before like
what you know there's always going to be
somebody that's offended by everything
there's there are people that are
offended by a woman literally being on
stage like they do not so like you you
can't not offend somebody but i think
like
as far as political correctness like try
like why
we should all be punching up i think and
i think a lot of the people that are
fighting for the right to
make fun of
minorities uh
why what is the purpose of that like why
do you have to put down a group that's
already fighting so hard to for equality
you know so that's that's my big
question what's why is that so important
and if you are doing something offensive
and you do feel like you have a good
point maybe you just haven't found the
right way to say it yet
um
yeah i mean i've killed jokes that i
thought
at the time were totally fine and now i
don't say them anymore because i just
don't feel like it's my place i you know
i think we all have
we all have our perspective and there
are certain things that i'm just like
you know what it's not my place to
decide whether or not i get to talk
about a certain group or whatever
because it's not my group i'm just if
they don't if that makes them
uncomfortable i respect that
you you bring up a good point on on
iterating jokes until they in some sense
are um you're just refining your own
jokes until you know you can get a whole
audience laughing at something there's
there's so much material that needs to
be joked about um
there's like there's there's real life
um issues that we face all we're talking
about this this complicated mess that is
the current state of humanity with
exponential technology and uh
what we're doing with the internet and
social media
there's so many jokes and wealth
inequality there's so many jokes
available in those domains
and yet we
for some reason are are yeah are
targeting um
other groups or individuals so there's
i would totally sway in the favor of
like enriching people's awareness by
talking about um complex subjects that
that are gonna again just open people up
to a new perspective on on on the world
that really needs to happen it's
it can be a little bit weird though
because there's like
you know you were saying also that that
someone will you know always be offended
by something and
and there's there's there seems to be a
little too much like coddling going on
like that people can't necessarily like
take a joke
do you see that as
an issue as well um
and that's interesting i feel like
uh my whole life people have been like
can you take a joke can't take a joke
when they are just like
making fun of women or like throwing
stereotypes at me and i'm like no that's
a bad joke it's an old joke it's a
stupid joke i'm done taking this joke
and so i don't really feel that way i i
um
sure there's always going to be i don't
think it's necessarily generational or
there's always going to be people who
are offended and
are crabby but i
no i'm so sick of like the same old
thing and like i don't want to have to
take a joke like i've taken jokes my
whole life i'm sick of it you know i
don't want people to and also i mean as
a white woman white women are such a
punchline right now in comedy
they are a punchline of every every
single group that is not a white woman
so like minorities as well as white
straight men are all using white women
not to say that we have it the hardest
we absolutely do not but um
yeah i don't want to have to laugh at
that i'm sick of it everybody's doing
the same joke
i'm not gonna laugh if it's not funny if
you hit me and you like you get me in an
unexpected place i will laugh and i will
laugh at myself but i'm s you know i
just feel like you in comedy you hear
the same thing over and over and over
and
i'm not gonna laugh if it's not funny
yeah ethics are evolving in many ways
and i think
uh one of comedies
if comedy has a goal towards some sort
of a truth i would say that it's comedy
has a goal of trying to help people
evolve their ethics more towards like an
equality of opportunity for all people
and to really see that like we are all
one and that we are all need to figure
out how to work together on this planet
and so that's like a cool goal of comedy
and there's in my opinion there's so
many ways to to to help identify the
evolution of ethics
this is so big because
let's move to to kids because kids and
children i don't think necessarily even
know that comedy is an option for them
a lot of the time we talk to comedians
when and they say
no
there's like really no real mentorship
or indication that you can make a career
out of comedy even writing writing there
is at least a little bit of an
indication that you can like make a
career out of writing but so yeah how
can you
maybe pass along some advice to young
people that might want to get involved
in comedy um i think that it's actually
really smart to go in if you're like
performing comedy to go in with the idea
that there is no
way to make a living like honestly
because like it will take so long that
like you should have a day job like
throw some energy into getting a day job
that is related um or getting a skill
that like you enjoy something to enrich
your life and also pay your rent while
you do this because performing is so
crazy and unpredictable and i'm so lucky
that i have writing and i was a writer
first um
but yeah i think a lot of people just
say oh i'm gonna do comedy and like
think that they're gonna be rich and
famous but
so many of my friends have had
half hours on comedy central and they're
like hey can i walk your dog i
can't quite make rent this month so it's
not easy
and it's not glamorous but i think that
if you get another skill it can
only help your comedy you'll have stuff
to talk about like you know you can do
jokes about your day job and going into
an office and it's hard and it's really
really tiring to basically have a double
life um
but you kind of gotta you have to do it
yeah that's also another part of this
like entrepreneurial hustle too is that
um the
the the self-sustaining grind is so
crucial it teaches you a lot um
and then to
yeah i like that that piece of advice
there's there's also something about
comedy that's like you gotta watch a lot
of the best and then kind of learn from
how they set up jokes and and and you
can practice that you're going to fall
on your face you know you talk about
this as well
so you're going to like lan you're going
to try and land jokes and you're going
to you're going to not succeed a bunch
and so you got to be resilient in that
sense absolutely yeah
let's let's talk a bit about that
resilience you know you had
um
you had in 2018 you had a a 100
rejections was your goal
and you actually got like 43 acceptances
and and so you got uh and you actually
you got you went up like a level or two
and some in some
opportunities and you strive for them
and you actually got got them which is
also really interesting and then you got
some really hard like rejections which
all like kind of builds you up to you
know to the story tell us about it um
yeah so my new year's resolution was a
hundred rejections for 2018 and i ended
up getting 104 um
and 104 rejections 43 acceptances i have
a couple still in my pending i'm not
really sure what's happening with this
pile a lot of my rejections were um just
no response which i think
i wrote about this for the new york
times and um a lot of the comments were
like well
are these no what are these people don't
even tell me no like how are you getting
all these no's and like no ghosting is a
no like
if it was dating you wouldn't be like
dating someone and be like oh well he
hasn't responded in my texts for a year
but we're still he's still my boyfriend
you know what i mean if somebody's
ghosting you in a professional setting
it's the same they don't want you
they're not interested they don't want
to buy what you're selling um
so it was a lot of that um
and it was a it was just a an experiment
that i did to try to reframe the way i
look at rejection
and to push myself a little bit farther
and see what i could get if i was just
being a little bit more
of a go-getter and i considered myself
to be an extremely hard worker and a
go-getter before that but um what would
an extra push do for me um and it did it
was it was wonderful i mean i got to do
things that i never thought i would have
been able to do
yeah and there's
there's also like you're you're you're
indicating like
a hundred
this is a great goal it's a great goal
to reach out to over a hundred um make
100 plus requests to get work and see
how your your background sort of tests
against what they're looking for in a
candidate and get feedback on that get
these gigs and
go through them
um
and i think there might even be
there's like a really deep lesson in
this of like perseverance and resilience
what do you think you gained from that
side of things
um
i think that i
sort of learned that like it's not bad
to ask for things and nobody's
really
not everyone's thinking about you so if
you want something you have to ask for
it and it's just so important and
i had these limitations on myself like i
always thought that i was like not smart
enough to write for the new yorker and i
always wanted to write shouts and
murders for the new yorker i read them
all the time they're so funny and i
submitted two pieces when they got in
and i'm like
i put these limitations on myself no one
told me that i was
not fit for it i told myself that so
i mean i just learned like i need to
erase all these things that i had
previously thought about myself um
yeah i think that that's kind of that's
kind to just push a little harder but
the other thing is that what i've
learned from balancing the idea off
people and telling them what i did like
i
reached for things that i was afraid
to reach for but also
it's not out of the realm of possibility
i wasn't like
i'm gonna try out for the wnba today and
then put that on my rejection list so i
think like if you're like 22 and you've
never done comedy don't be like hey can
i headline caroline's like you know what
i mean like you need to like put in the
work of going to those open mics for a
couple years then start your own bar
show ask for other similar shows like
ask for things that are a step or two
above you but not 20 steps above you so
that's another
piece of it yeah those are really good
pieces of feedback so wherever we're at
with
what we're doing what we're passionate
about what we mean what we find most
meaningful in life it's that we really
got to stretch ourselves to take more
opportunities and seize those doors that
are kind of available to us by
making a cool resolution like i'm gonna
go and ask these hundred doors i'm gonna
go and knock at these doors and the ones
that are a level or two above you is
also really good to go and try and and
dig in and find these connections and
build these networks and
i like your example of like i didn't
just go try out for the wnba
and add that to my rejection list yeah
okay um
other things that you think are
important to address before we get to
these last couple of questions um in
regards to the rejection project or just
any in general yeah comedy writing
gosh um i i just i didn't everyone says
like oh when you get into this it's
gonna be so hard and there's gonna be so
much rejection and i was like yeah i
know and then when you like
do an experiment like this or like make
a resolution where you're actually
listing your rejections like it made me
really see it differently see it for the
first time in that way where you're like
wow you know like my one of my new
year's resolutions this year is to do
one
item of self-care a week because i
realized after looking at all this
rejection that like i was really putting
myself through a lot and like i have to
i don't know we should just be nice to
ourselves like it's so hard to
do this and if you're in a field where
you're getting rejected all the time
like
go and get a massage like go get your
nails done go do something for yourself
take yourself out to eat like because
it's actually
really affecting you you know and i just
didn't realize like
how much
there all this negativity in my life
like that it was also present and so now
i'm trying to be more mindful of the
negativity that i'm bringing into my
life as i'm like trying to
ascend in my career
yeah the two points there first is like
listing the reason why you get um what
your rejections are
i've saved a bunch of my rejections and
like i go and look at them because it's
really important for me to like
to like motivate myself to want to
achieve more and i like motivate myself
by doing that
um
and also like
um another thing is
you know you talk about self-care
self-care is really important
and
knowing what
brings us to a state of of calm and a
state of whatever we want to do in the
flow and like how do we get there most
effectively and like triggering that um
within ourselves
okay we we started the conversation
talking about how complex and messy
civilization has become what are some of
your
solutions to the mess oh i don't know i
just hope that somebody else figures it
out
i don't know this is the thing like i i
don't know how to save the world like i
just i i try to vote right and donate
money to organizations i believe in
and i try not to eat meat and i that's
like
i don't know i'm trying to not by fast
fashion um
but
i just
i all i know are like things that i can
do on
in my life on my level to try to be
responsible but um
i don't
have like
big scale answers i think we need a
different president uh for sure
uh
yeah
i think we need more you know what we
need women we need more women there's a
lot more now um in this freshman class
of
but
i think more women in politics in
general would be really helpful i think
we have all the answers and we can save
the world we're just we're not we're i'm
sorry but men are
just inherently slightly more evil i
think
we have to have control
there's i think there's quite a bit of
um
of a neurodiversity of diversity and
thinking that needs to enter the
political sphere um and into just
stewardship sphere in general um yeah a
lot of the people that are of of um of
great um
like corruption and greed and evil
malevolence etc are in many ways are are
men and
that
i always like to run the simulation of
what it would have evolved like if it
was a matriarchy
yeah like how would things have evolved
and then what i what i do after that is
then i take the best
of what could have evolved as a
matriarchy and the best of what evolves
as a patriarchy and i try and smash
those things together into like an
equality
and i hope that's where that's where we
get
what do you think about what do you
think oh i think the world's gonna
blow up before that happens um
i'm not very optimistic i don't know
we're all going to be living on a moon
on the moon um
yeah i don't know i
i think that's wha what what is the best
case scenario for a matriarchy
yeah that's a great question i'm glad
you asked that um i think the amount of
nurture that occurs that especially that
both in like social relationships and
also also um between
um
children and
and mothers and parents but i think
that's a really good one is the level of
nurture
i do think
that women have we're we're
i mean i see this this thing where women
are very hard workers because we're told
like
since we're
children that you have to work super
hard to get what you want and you have
to you know you got to
be
get great grades and you have to be
pretty and you got to play sports and
you got to do all these things and i
feel like for some reason in my
generation and this like millennial i'm
like on the older side of millennials
but um
the guys are really not matching i mean
i'm not saying anything new the idea of
a man-child but um
it's really a wild
and interesting phenomenon
and i just see it across my generation
that's not to say there aren't
millennial men who have worked really
hard and are super talented but like
overall like the women are just like
dedicated hard workers and i feel like
guys were like i'm okay with the c and
uh i just like want to play my video
games you know like they're like i don't
really need to be on honor roll i just
need to be happy and like it's just
it's so different how we were raised
man i wonder
like we were talking earlier about how
like people can't really get offended by
facts like people shouldn't be offended
by facts and
you know it'd be interesting to see what
some of the like factual data is
here men have a
boys have a proclivity to play video
games
uh girls have a proclivity to talk to
each other on social media and stuff
like that
and so it's just like trying to figure
out where this all comes from
yeah part of it and then also like
yeah also just again running the actual
simulation of what it would be like to
have a full-fledged
matriarchy and take the best from that a
full-fledged patriarch you have the best
from that
or you know run a full-fledged equal
equality of opportunity um experiment
and then
see what that would actually look like
yeah
okay what what is a
core driving principle of yours
um
um
that's so interesting i used to have my
my i would always joke with my sister my
old motto is most people are stupid and
stuck uh
and it just helps me get through the
world um
uh
but it's pretty negative isn't it um i
do sort of believe that and it does i
find it very helpful
uh because i i tend i think also as a
woman to really worry about what people
think about me and really get in my head
and tell myself that i'm not worthy
enough so when i remind myself that most
people are stupid and suck um
it helps me be confident actually so in
a way it is sort of a positive spin i
think i will hold on to that mantra for
a little while longer in fact
my fiance's like the most positive man
in the world and like he would be so
horrified to hear this right now
yeah and i was thinking as you were
saying that like i can see how it could
potentially
you know benefit
someone but i'll just like
for like maybe for you to say that but
at the same time it's like
we like to try and humanize right we
like to try and find the real good in in
each other
right but i think if you approach it
like if you approach other people with
like
i'm not afraid of you i'm not afraid to
be me in front of you
and that's kind of like where
most people are stupid and suck really
helps me out you know and then you're
pleasantly surprised by people um
yeah i i don't like
the the idea that everyone is inherently
good is a little condescending to me
i don't know um i think i i think it
helps me
my brain is broken too i'm like a i have
comedy brain i have depression and
anxiety
uh and all that so for me to i think i
just need more of a negative place to
start it just helps me function i mean
this you're talking to a girl who
my goal was a hundred rejections last
year so i really come from a sad place
big
that i like work from there but i i
guess maybe like that's part of uh just
what helps me
what helps me move through the world
now if you could rebuild civilization
from scratch how would you design it
um pink uh no um
i don't know oh god i would put new york
city and hollywood in the same place
uh that is one thing that's very
annoying um
uh what else what else what else i don't
i've never thought about that that's so
interesting um
gosh
if you would ask me like 10 years ago it
would have been like
dude i think we should all live with our
friends in like communal like
settings and then like all raise each
other's babies and i'm like i think what
i'm describing is a cult um
but i always thought that would be
really fun
[Music]
i don't know i think more sports bras
less
high heels can we go with that i'm down
i'm down yeah yeah
yeah that's
comfortability yeah yeah comfortability
um
how about
do you think this is a simulation
uh everything's a simulation no i don't
understand simulation is like a
like a
i you know what it would be kind of nice
wouldn't it just like take
some of the um
stress off if this was a simulation why
am i so stressed out i shouldn't be i
don't have any free will at the end of
the day
i kind of hope it's a simulation
oh it actually makes me feel really
happy to think about that
do you think it's a simulation
there's some good arguments for it
yeah
does it make you feel happy when you
think about it i just got so happy yeah
well um i think that we will soon be
potentially writing our and computing
our own simulation of the evolution of a
planet orbiting a star and then we'll
see ourselves evolving in that
simulation and we'll be like oh
so
this is just another level
uh oh my god i'm gonna have such trouble
writing jokes about this it's
it's too cerebral
it's very exciting though i think it's a
really good um thought experiment and
i'm just ready for like the end the end
screen like
you leveled up 17 times gained 3 400
experience points here's all the trash
that you use then it just like truck
like dumps trash oh my god
so you should have used less trash in
your life
yeah just funny yeah
stuff like that could be funny
okay last question is what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world
oh that's such a sweet question um
i mean this is so hokey but love i mean
when i am laying in bed with my fiance
and our pit bull and we are all just
snuggled up together i think it is the
most beautiful thing and the best
feeling in the world and
um
it makes me feel like i have
a reason
to do all the [ __ ] of living you
know just get up do my work try really
hard it
that moment is the perfect moment yeah
what about you yeah um
i like i like i like yours a lot we hear
we hear love a lot loves love is a
really important one you you make it
clear that um
that it's so profound for you that it
makes everything else you know worth
living that's that's really beautiful
um
yeah probably that the fact that we
somehow managed to evolve here on earth
and you know we find ourselves here as
stewards of the planet and we have to
figure out how to work together because
yeah if we don't um
be uh
be a sad thing if we don't so i want to
figure out how to do that and so i think
that's that's that's that's the most
beautiful thing the earth and all of its
inhabitants including animals plants etc
thanks for asking yeah yeah
and thanks for joining us thank you for
having me on really appreciate it thanks
for coming on
uh and everyone check out emily's work
in the links in the bio go and check it
out let us know your thoughts on the
episodes we'd love to hear from you in
the comments below let's get the
conversations rolling about how to more
easily succeed with our goals and go and
launch ourselves out to more
opportunities and not be fearful of
rejections pick up some comedy pick up
some writing go do your thing also
go and build the future everyone to
manifest your destiny into the world we
love you very much and we will see you
soon
peace